Luke and Tom here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel we're going to teach you
how to build a fire not only that we're
going to show you different types of
fire starters we're going to show you
some fire safety tips and I'm going to
teach you how to build a one-match fire
in any type of weather condition they're
going to be tips and tricks for both the
beginner and the season to outdoorsmen
well I'm probably the best place you
could ever imagine for gathering
campfire wood so with that let me talk
to you about the three types of campfire
wood there's tinder kindling and fuel
okay tinder is the small stuff it's the
little fine stuff that you light without
right after you light your match the
kindling is the medium-sized stuff that
you use to grow your fire to the desired
size and the stuff I call fuel is the
big stuff it's the logs that you use to
maintain the fire keep it going by far
the most common rookie mistake when
building a campfire is not gathering
enough wood when you light that match
you want to have everything you need
right there ready to go you don't want
to have to leave your fire unattended to
run off into the woods and find more
wood so get everything ready get it
ready to go then light your match in
order to know how much wood you're going
to need for your campfire here's some
things that you should know an average
normal campfire typically burns about
four to six logs at any given time
additionally a log you lose is about one
inch of radius for every hour of burning
alright so let me give you an example
this log is three inches across right
here so after about one hour you'll lose
about one inch off the surface area of
the log so after about one hour in the
fire this is a piece of charcoal about
that big a charred log about that big is
all it's going to be left
that's leaves about half an inch there
so this log will be completely gone in
about an hour and a half give or take
now of course how hot the fire is the
type of wood you have whether it's a
hard wood versus a soft wood whether
it's dry versus green that will all
affect the time but rough estimate about
one inch per hour is what you're going
to lose so if you want to camp fire
that's going to last six hours that's
360 minutes okay one of these logs lasts
90 minutes so you need four of these
logs to last six hours on a one log fire
if you want a five log fire then you're
going to need 20 of these okay so just
for the fuel for your fire you'll need
20 logs just like this for six hours of
campfire cooking s'mores sitting around
the fire if you don't have logs with you
go out and find them this log here is
about three inches in diameter so that's
about an hour and a half of burn time
right there and just top this sucker up
into sections and you've got several
hours of burning if you come across wood
like this I believe this is treated
lumber okay it's treated with a chemical
to keep it from rotting this is stuff
used in decks and a lot of exterior
building don't use treated or painted
wood as fuel in your fire or kindling in
your fire because the chemicals when
they burn can be very toxic so if you
find treated wood leave it alone have
seven logs that are averaging about
three inches in diameter so about an
hour and a half for each log building
about a four or five log fire so I have
roughly three hours of burn time more
than double what I probably need today
okay let's talk about kindling
kindling is the medium-sized fuel that
helps grow your fire it takes it from
the tender all the way up to the logs
and the roaring fire that we like to sit
by so having kindling these different
sizes is really important you want to
start off with little tiny stuff about
the thickness of a toothpick and work
your way up to things about one inch in
diameter or even bigger the length of
the kindling doesn't really matter it's
the diameter of the kindling and a
condition of the kindling that's
important here getting kindling you want
it to be dry you want it to be very dead
and ideally you'd like it to be like a
spruce or a pint
anything that has needles and sev leaves
generally burns really well when it's
dry and dead dry dead kindling will snap
and break apart pretty easily green
kindling
does it like to do that the easier and
crisper it snaps the better the kindling
additionally wood can be cheesy if it's
crumbly and it's falling apart like this
it's two decades and it usually doesn't
make very good Kinley because it holds
moisture inside you can feel it and it's
kind of wet like a sponge so if it comes
apart in your hand it's not very good
kindling when you go camping in national
or state parks you'll often find that
there's rules against gathering your own
firewood now situation when you need
kindling and tinder you can make it from
your own log simply take your logs and
split them into smaller pieces till you
get the nice variety of different sized
kindling when you're chopping kindling
you want to make sure not to cut your
fingers off so put the axe on a small
piece and beat it that way keep your
fingers safe
[Music]
if you have a log do you want to break
up and you don't have a saw or ax handy
don't worry just find two trees they're
close together and you can break them
that will also do it there you go
okay I've got enough kindling but now I
want to sort it and segregate it out
into about six different piles sorted by
sizes and I want everything from the
little tiny stuff all the way up to the
big fuel I want to have it all piled up
nice and easy to get to when I like to
match so if you get in this habit of
doing this and doing it right you'll be
able to build one match fires in all
sorts of conditions no matter how nasty
again is you're sorting this wood you're
not sorting it by length you're sorting
it by diameter I want to make sure
everything short enough to fit into your
fire pit
strictly speaking this is probably more
kindling than I need but you know it's
better to overkill it and have leftovers
then under do it and have to start all
over again well I don't have it in
separate distinct piles you can see it
kind of goes from the big stuff down to
the little tiny stuff okay let's talk
about tinder tinder is the first thing
you light when you're starting a fire
whether it's a match a lighter or flint
and steel or you're using a bow or you
know whatever it is my personal favorite
tinder is crumpled up newspaper
hands-down I love the stuff cardboard
works really well but there's lots of
Tinder's available some people swear by
dryer lint or they take cotton balls
soaked in Vaseline some people like to
use large quantities of lighter fluid
wood shavings is another type of tinder
that I really like because no matter
where you are as long as you have a
knife or a sharp axe you can make it
often you'll see rookies try to use dry
leaves as tender and most dry leaves do
not work very well as tinder at all it
just kind of smolders and it doesn't
actually catch fire and produce a lot of
heat
so as you can see the paper lid on fire
the easiest the fastest and burned the
brightest the wood shavings are doing a
very decent second place and the
cardboard is not doing bad it's kind of
more of a slow burn would leave leaves
just don't really do much they they have
a hard time keeping a flame see look at
that you can get them going but they
just go out so easy you'll end up
wasting a lot of matches trying to get
it started so forget the leaves
cardboard paper wood shavings those work
best okay when you build the campfire
you want to make sure you do it in a
safe spot the ideal situation is to only
build campfires and designated fire pits
but here in a situation when you don't
have those you have to make your own you
want at least a minimum of 12 feet of
cleared ground
there's nothing burnable within twelve
feet bigger would be better now you're
in a situation where there's extremely
dry and dangerous conditions or if
you're burning wood that throws a lot of
sparks or if you're going to be building
a big fire you're going to need a better
spot than what I have here but for today
for the small little fighter we're going
to be demonstrating this will be alright
[Music]
all right so there we go we got this
nice little channel where cold air can
come in get ignited with the fire and
the hot air comes up you're ever going
to be playing with fire make sure you
have something to put the fire out close
at hand these are a fire extinguisher or
a five-gallon bucket of water or even a
bucket of sand things can get out of
hand really quick you want to make sure
you're prepared if they do what I have
here is some wood shavings for tinder
and my really small kindling piled on
top and it's not any sort of neat and
organized manner just a big healthy pile
fire and heat always rises so you want
to put the stuff you're going to light
the tinder on the very bottom of the
pile so the heat from the tinder comes
up in lights the kindling on fire once
you get everything ready and built it
should only take one match daddy there
we go
box is old when a fire is smoking a lot
like this it means it's being smothered
it's not getting enough oxygen so I like
to take my plate and just give it a good
fan you once you get it a little bit of
oxygen it stops smoking
now you can use a dinner plate to fan it
yeah you can use your breath I even have
a lid to a Tupperware bin that I keep
all my camping stuff in and it works
great for fanning fires
okay once the fire tape start adding
bigger slop and see it's starting to
smoke again because I'm putting a little
too much on there not getting enough
oxygen just give it a little Fanning
actually be better if I did over here by
this hole I know big stuff you can see
how there's water bubbling out of the
wood that snaps it's boiling and being
forced out of the force because the wood
is still green green wood means it still
has staff in it if you buy seasoned
firewood that's firewood that's been
dried and it won't do that as much if
you bunch the logs up too close together
you won't get enough oxygen and the fire
will start to smoke if you spread the
logs out too far apart they won't share
each other's heat and the fire will die
as the fire consumes fuel the shape of
the fire and the gaps in between the
logs changes so you're constantly
adjusting the logs and moving them
closer together having a big roaring
fire with lots of flame is great when
you're hanging around and talking and
keeping warm with a group in a survival
situation however a small fire you can
get close to is often a lot more
practical it takes less energy to build
and it will keep you warmer if you're
cooking having a fire with lots of
burned out coals so it's just mostly
coals and very little flame is usually
the ideal fire for cooking oh I think
you lost your marshmallow hard to be
done roasted marshmallow when you're
putting out a campfire with a bucket of
water there's two things to remember
first off when you dump water on the
fire they'll be a big plume of hot ash
and hot steam so if you're leaning over
the fire you're going to get a face full
of hot steam and burn yourself secondly
when you drizzle the water on you want
to saturate everything the wood the
ashes and mix it all up until there's no
more smoke no more steam and you can't
feel any more heat coming from the ashes
if you're not thorough the fire will
reignite
[Music]
so it looks like I put the fire out
feels relatively cool but it's a trick
you got to really dump that water on
there and mix it all up because deep
inside there's burning embers on the
under sides of these logs and as soon as
that water is evaporated flames are
going to come back
you
well sure enough this fire came back to
life so we're going to show you how to
put it out properly step dumping a whole
bunch kind of sprinkle it alone okay
then spread out the logs and turn over
the logs and start stirring up the coals
and get all that water mixed in
underneath well when you actually
sprinkle the water on and stir up the
coals and take down and disassemble the
fire you can more thoroughly put out the
fire with the third the water well I
told you guys that I teach you how to
build a one-match fire and even the
worst condition and it looks like we're
going to get a chance to do just that
because it's starting to rain all right
let's get our jackets on we've got a
real storm coming today the worst
conditions the more kindling you're
going to need in this situation I'm
using two to three times the normal
amount especially with the fine stuff
and being organized and prepared is even
more important additionally you're going
to need a shelter to protect your match
from being put out immediately by the
rain
so this lid is what I'm using right now
wood shavings are great tinder in wet
conditions because you can shave off the
wet wood get down to the dry shaving
having 100% dry tinder is absolutely
vital so if you can't make tinder in a
dry environment keep your matches and
tinder in a waterproof bag until you're
100% ready to go then pile as much of
your finest kindling on top of the bag
as you can manage and try to build a
little bit of a shelter or protection
also dig a trench to make sure that the
water doesn't pile up in the bottom of
your fire pit because that will cause
you real problems then I open the bag
and strike the match and light the
tinder inside the bag and let the fire
consume the bag then start blowing and
Fanning the flame as aggressively as you
can and keep piling on as much kindling
as you can big vertical piles of Kinley
act as a roof over your fire and also
gives the heat of the flames a chance to
dry out the kindling of course this
smothers the fire so you've got to stand
it as much as you can to keep it from
going out don't let the fire hollow out
your pile so keep shoving more wood
inside and compressing it down and then
take the big logs and use them
make a little bit of a route to keep the
rain from putting out your fire then
keep Fanning those flames until those
logs catch on fire
[Music]
who didn't sale is going to be easy but
that's how you build a one-match fire
and even the worst condition just double
and triple the amount of tinder you use
double and triple amount of kindling you
use to put a lot of elbow grease into
spamming up fanning those planes well
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
to put out new videos every week feels
nice